is there anybody that you can trust in
that lifestyle
I mean you know you know you can ask
even Master Jay seemed like he might be
less than trustworthy sometimes right
you know so it's it's
you might even be close to people and
and you know
you got to realize at the end of the day
you're number one so that means you're
not as close to people as you think well
I mean if they're on crack or meth or
whatever fentanyl they are that's their
first priority yeah so they'll Rob from
you to get what they need right and then
yeah it doesn't mean that they're a
crook but but they're behaving like a
crook right so it's it's not it's not
very the trustworthy uh status is very
very minimal
it's minimal
if you could have had your life take any
different direction what would you have
loved to see happen with little Mama's
life
foreign